son pocos los residentes que se atreven
a caminar por las ruinas de mariupol la
artillería rusa ensombreció en la ciudad
edificios devastados vehículos
calcinados restos de metralla
improvisadas tumbas más de 100 mil
ucranianos continúan atrapados bajo los
ataques del kremlin muchos sobreviven en
los gélidos refugios subterráneos
estamos durmiendo en los sótanos hace
mucho frío se necesita media noche para
calentar la una miedo y no sé cómo vamos
a sobrevivir este hospital ahora está en
manos de separatistas prorrusas trató de
evacuar la ciudad de cristal ya que está
bien hecho fuimos evacuados aquí y la
gente esperó durante algún tiempo al
menos ya no nos disparaban aquí está un
poco más tranquila venimos del edificio
de allá nuestros dos bloques quedaron
intactos casi de milagro el resto son
como acertijos todo se quemó por
completo al lado del mercado 100
personas murieron en un edificio el
bloque se derrumbó y eso fue todo
y esto a wichita mokaba está chido y el
viernes las autoridades de mariupol
dijeron que 300 personas murieron en el
bombardeo ruso de un teatro la semana
pasada hospitales de maternidad teatros
que son refugios de los civiles escuelas
la brutalidad rusa no da tregua miles de
personas han salido como desplazados de
la urbe en su vida con maneras blancas
tuvieron que pasar hasta 30 puestos de
control comandados por tropas de la
federación rusa
por desgracia no queda nada en mayúscula
la están bombardeando con armas salvajes
no sé la última semana ha habido
explosiones como nunca antes había oído
atacar zonas residenciales con cohetes
que todavía queda mucha gente los
muertos yacen cubiertos con telas en las
calles no hay nadie que los entierren
las fuerzas ucranianas aseguran que
siguen oponiendo resistencia y
protegiendo la ciudad portuaria donde
más de 2.000 personas habrían muerto por
los ataques